[Music]
Mr
mandles this is Bella hello
Bella
oh Bud blood Bud
[Music]
blood Yus and I started talking about
poor things in 2017 the idea of having a
brain that is brand new what would that
be where did she come from She's an
experiment she's progressing at an Exel
piece I was blown away by Bella by the
character I don't think I've ever seen
or read anyone like that working with
Emma that's the reason this film for me
was so exciting to make B
out my character the doctor sees her as
an experiment which at some point
reaches a crisis I can't let you go if
you do not B should turn rotten with
hate I must set forth into
Waters that you could have the kind of
mind that isn't taught to be a certain
way I think that's very
inspiring all of these things that women
are conditioned a whole lifetime through
do not apply to her you'll confine
yourself to three phrases how marvelous
delighted and how do they make the
pastry so crisp yes you get some very
funny
situations
oh andem it is unbelievable the
development of the brain it's such a
fine line especially as we shoot things
out of order and she's really tracking
the progression not just with her voice
but also with her body it's an
incredibly challenging part it's
probably the hardest part I've ever
played a woman plotting her course to
Freedom how a
lot it's a huge leap for her forward
that's incredible to witness I don't
know how this could have been made
without her
I wanted to play Bella because it felt
like acceptance of what it is to be a
woman what it is to be free what it is
to be confident and just a little
bit we will need less of your tongue in
the future but overall most agreeable it
just felt like the perfect combination
of all of
[Music]
that